[Music]
a show of unity or a final roll of the
dice leaders of the per Thai party
runners-up in the general election and
others unveil a coalition that they say
can Garner enough support to take power
we the six Coalition parties would like
to ask the people to have confidence in
poor time
and all parties that will form the
government we ask for your support and
together we will help solve this crisis
so the country is able to move on for
the best interests of all people
but to get a majority in the lower house
they'll probably have to bring
military-backed parties into the
Coalition something they promised voters
they wouldn't do
and their Coalition Partners will want
powerful Ministries possibly even the
prime minister's job
no it would not be the government of the
popular will because it was cleared at
the the vote on May 14th was for Change
and that's why they people bought it for
the move forward party which was the
largest winning and then putai party
together they combined for two-thirds of
all the votes that were cast even if one
of the two major parties does get a
majority here in Parliament it'll be
with Coalition Partners who won't allow
a reform agenda and who have power
sharing demands done behind closed doors
former prime minister tax in shinawa in
self-imposed exile for the past 17 years
has delayed his much-anticipated return
his political allies thought they'd be
in power by now but judicial
interference has thrown the path to the
Premiership into doubt
one Exile has returned however a son of
King Vegeta banished to the U.S three
decades ago when his mother was divorced
now he's made a surprise a visit and
what he says is a private capacity but
in the full glare of the public eye
I am delighted to return to Thailand I
have been warmly welcomed it's been a
long time away 27 years it's like a
dream come true to be back here the
palace remains tight-lipped about his
return but the timing during this period
of transition may not be a coincidence
Tony Chang altazira Bangkok
foreign